so you said there are people in
concentration camps in China who are
making the solar panels that's right
that's so bad really there's three
groups that should be blamed there's the
politicians there's the news media and
then there's the activists and they all
kind of manipulate each other people are
going to die in Europe because energy is
too expensive because governments in
Europe have been funding concentration
camps in China yes
[Music]
before we get started this episode of
the podcast is sponsored by rabbit air
for people who suffer from them living
with allergies can range from mild to
miserable and in rare cases like mine
allergies can make your face look like
you weigh 50 pounds more than you do if
you look at old podcasts from March last
year and wonder why occasionally I look
like a different person it's because I'm
so allergic to trees and the outdoors
that my face swells it's super cute
thankfully rabbit airs HEPA air
purifiers filter out 99.97 of the
allergens and pollutants from the air
it's always the perfect time to get one
of these for your home office space or
your bedroom or anywhere really a lot of
people suffer from allergies without
realizing it so if you're someone who
wakes up with a stuffy nose or you're
congested all the time or you get colds
and that turns into bronchitis it could
be because of allergies given we breathe
in nearly 2 000 gallons of air clean the
air in your house can really reduce
immune responses to allergens if your
kids they're waking up with stuffy noses
allergies could be the issue as well the
filters have really helped me I have one
glown in the back over there and I like
how they sound and look they don't look
nerdy like you're someone who's allergic
to everything they're cool they're Sleek
they're quiet you can get your rabbit
air air purifier today by going to Rapid
air.com to see their models or call them
24 7 to speak to a rapid air consultant
that's
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r.com enjoy this episode
Michael schallenberger welcome to my
podcast
thanks for having me Michaela I have
been looking forward to speaking with
you for quite a while so I'm really glad
you could come on
um before we get started for anyone
who's not familiar with you can you give
a brief background about who you are and
what it is you do sure I'm a an author a
journalist I'm also an advocate for uh
abundance energy I've been an
environmental advocate for 30 years and
I'm also uh in the last few years I've
become Advocate I become an advocate of
of expanding uh drug and psychiatric
care for people that are homeless and
completing uh helping to lead a national
increasingly National Coalition to
address the addiction and psychiatric
crisis in North America oh interesting
okay I didn't know that you were
interested in that okay we could talk
about that as well sure what are you
doing politically nowadays well you may
know that I ran for governor in
California and I came in third which was
on the one hand really exciting because
it's more than any independent candidate
had ever received as Governor we only
had a three we only ran we were only
gotten super late so we only had a few
months long campaign but also
disappointing because we didn't make the
runoff and so we weren't able to fully
kind of call the questions on the future
of California which is you know has a
bunch of big issues around homelessness
being maybe the biggest one but also
around energy and water so I'm a
political independent I uh as a young
man I was on the radical left I became I
become more moderate obviously since
then but also have felt like the left
has gone crazy
um over the last decade or so so now I
identify as a as an independent and I am
not a member of any political party cool
so do you think the issues California is
facing you think the major issue is
homelessness well if I had to really get
to the bottom of it I would say the main
issue is nihilism it's the the I think
we're dealing with the consequences of
people who are trying to do with their
Politics the what religion used to do
and they're doing so unknowingly and so
one of the I just I published a piece
today where I described that you know
people you know particularly Democrats
progressives they say things that are
just obviously false about climate
change they say that it's increasing
natural disasters it's not doing that
natural disasters are actually going
down because deaths from extreme weather
events are going down the cost of
extreme weather events are going down so
the number of disasters is going down
they claim that they are that you know
Renewables can power the world and that
Renewables already cost effective or
cheaper than existing power even as they
demand huge subsidies for Renewables so
they're you know and sometimes it's
deliberate they know that they're being
misleading but other times I think
they're just in the grip of a religion
but they don't think of it as a religion
of all they think they're just telling
the truth so I think that part of what
is going on with California is that
we're dealing with a very Progressive
State a very Progressive population that
you know no longer Believes In
traditional religion they moved away
from all of that whether you know you
know Judaism Christianity Hinduism but
they've ended up creating a new religion
out of vocalism and of wokism one of the
sub-variants of course this apocalyptic
environmentalism but also it includes
this obsession with race this obsession
with sexual identity and so I would say
that's the underlying problem is that we
keep undermining the bases of
civilization out of this what I'm
calling Progressive nihilism that also
happens to be the name of the third book
in this Trilogy that I'm writing which
started with apocalypse never and then
was San Francisco last year and will be
Progressive nihilism in 2024. oh that's
that's exciting hopefully that'll help
people uh how much yeah yeah hopefully
well San Francisco is very interesting I
enjoyed that a lot I'd recommend that
that was fun that was a great title too
thank you can you describe a bit about
what's going on in Europe in regards to
energy because I think a lot of people
here don't really understand the
ramifications of increased energy prices
or why the energy and prices increase in
the first place sure so Europe is in the
worst energy crisis at least in 50 years
but maybe in its entire history it made
a decision you know 10 20 years ago the
big countries did that they were going
to reduce their Reliance on nuclear
power plants also on coal plants and
they were going to rely more on natural
gas imported from Russia and more on
solar panels and wind turbines
modestly imported from China and so what
we saw is that Europe produced three
times more natural gas than than Russia
did 15 years ago but those numbers
totally changed and so Europe uh now has
become completely dependent on Russia
for natural gas there was already an
energy crisis last year that was brewing
but it has has worsened now because
Russia in retaliation for Europe's
support of Ukraine has has basically cut
off almost all natural gas to Europe and
and the continent is supposed to shut
off that's it's petroleum or oil imports
as well so you know they there's a lot
of people that say well Europe is going
to be able to get through the winter
they've saved up enough natural gas but
that overlooks something really
important which is that they don't have
enough natural gas to support the
industries that depend on the natural
gas and that includes things like
aluminum steel glass Plastics
fertilizers so the consequences are
extremely serious not just for your
Europe you know Europe and Europe about
70 percent of the fertilizer production
has gone down as is shut down so they're
only producing you know somewhere
between 20 and 30 percent of the
fertilizers they were producing that
means that we're just going to produce
less food and that means that there's
going to be hunger estimated at 350
million people are going to die of
hunger related diseases this year those
numbers are going to go up it's going to
only get worse over the next several
years we see that about half the steel
production is shut down in Europe so
what's really happening that's
terrifying should be terrifying to
people that care about Europe is that
they're deindustrializing we're going to
actually do really well in the United
States and Canada because we have
abundant oil and gas and a bunch of
energy and so a lot of those fertilizer
steel manufacturing companies are going
to come from Europe and relocating the
United States but those of us anybody
that cares about Europe should be very
concerned about what's going on right
now and of course Americans we have an
obligation the treaty obligation to
protect Europe in terms of National
Security but if they don't have
sufficient energy then it creates all
sorts of risks to them in terms of
national security so if there's a treaty
obligation then are we in some way
obligated to provide natural gas the
only uh no I mean that's the that's the
reason we're not I mean if there were
then we would be doing it I presume but
no I mean it's more like you know
Ukraine obviously was not part of the EU
or part of NATO so when Russia invaded
the United States you know the Europe
and the United States didn't really have
any basis to defend it it ended up
supporting it with arms you know the
concern of course is that it would
somehow entangle the United States or
Europe in that war and you sort of see
Russia now threatening making all sorts
of threats because they've had some
setbacks but it's more like
um you know it's more like the kind of
thing you worry about is that Europe
ends up in a situation like it was in
before World War II where you end up in
a severe economic depression you end up
with hyperinflation and you ended up
getting leaders in Europe who are very
you know scary and authoritarian Who
start to do things like you know
deprived people of democracy they start
taking other measures that really
undermine liberal democracy in Europe
the why aren't U.S and Canada why
haven't they stepped in to provide
natural gas to Europe like I believe I
can't remember where I heard this from I
think it was my dad said that people had
come to Trudeau I don't remember if it
was the chancellor of Germany something
like that had come to Trudeau and said
hey we're in deep trouble can you
provide us natural gas and Trudeau had
just been like no the environment is at
risk
is that true yes that's exactly what
happened so the chancellor of Germany
Olaf Shoals went to Canada I believe
late last month and was begging for
little Financial gas exports you know
Canada is rich in natural gas so it's
the United States you know there are
there are genuine logistical challenges
it takes three years to build a gas
liquid with a faction terminal that's a
terminal that cools natural gas uh to
very low levels and that turns the gas
into a liquid and then you can put on a
ship and send it to Europe it takes a
while to build those but Europe you know
Europe's in trouble for a while so one
the I think the obvious response would
be for Trudeau the prime minister of
Canada and President Biden to say yeah
we're going to expedite the production
of liquefaction terminals we're going to
get them to Europe we're all in this
together it's obviously also very good
for the economies of Canada in the
United States to be sending gas to
Europe and it's also good for the
environment because without the natural
gas the the Europeans are burning more
coal more diesel more kerosene they're
also burning wood which is the dirtiest
fuel so it's it's crazy it's because
both Trudeau and Biden are scared of
upsetting their very Progressive voting
base and so that's why they're not doing
it but it's a sign of real political
cowardice because they both have to know
both true and bite and have to know that
they're really hurting Europe by not
stepping up by expanding gas production
yeah I mean you just described why they
should do it in like 25 seconds you
don't think like you'd think that that
oh they know subscribe to people but I
mean just say like there are people's
lives at risk here like even the
progressive left because they work on
compassion right they could probably get
behind hey we need to do this for now
because people are going to freeze to
death can you not support that they
can't just say well no we're not
supporting that not really it doesn't
make them look good it's a strange
situation well you got it and I think
your point is well taken that that the
core value for the left is ostensibly
compassion now of course the thing
that's undermining that is this idea
that climate change is an apocalyptic
threat and so if you think that climate
change is a world-ending threat and you
think that
I mean it's not irrational I think
trying to try to make it rational but if
you think that more gas production is
going to lock us into the apocalypse
that's how they justify it that's how
the activists justify it the politicians
justify it because they're scared of the
activists they're scared of the voters
they're scared of the news media is
completely Bonkers you know if any I
mean really there's three groups that
should be blamed there's the politicians
there's the news media and then there's
the activists um and they all kind of
manipulate each other but I do think the
crisis is going to get so bad that
you're going to see significant
political change really everywhere
um including in North America but also
in Europe and we just did we've seen the
conservative governments now come to
power in Sweden and Italy I think that's
going to continue to happen and so
there's a way in which the
contradictions are piling up and you're
going to start to see the these
anti-energy nihilistic behaviors start
to uh that people are going to start to
self-destruct do you think this is
correctable with the right government
for these European countries or these
European countries really screwed it's
definitely correctable I mean it'll be
hard and I think that you saw The
Italian the the incoming new Italian
Prime Minister I believe her name is
Maloney strike in a very conciliatory
speech and also I think a very humble
speech saying that she was going to you
know they were all in this together and
that this was going to be very difficult
that's the right posture to have this is
not a moment for a lot of swagger by
anybody but they just need to do
everything they can to bring down Energy
prices I mean that's just the main event
so they are going to need to burn a lot
of coal they're going to need to import
a lot of liquid Financial gas they're
going to need to keep their nuclear
plants operating or restart the nuclear
plants unfortunately the opposite is
happening in both Belgium and Germany
they're continuing to shut down nuclear
power plants which is like insane so
there's just a lot that they're
struggling but there's a lot that they
can do you know in the short term and
medium term in particular so that's I
think but you're asking the right
question like how much is Maloney really
going to do I would say in the short
term it's going to be pretty difficult
but I think in the medium term
more like
three to five years the right policies
now will make a big difference I
remember growing up hearing how
dangerous nuclear power was I remember
that that was just what I heard it was I
didn't know very much about it but it
was dangerous it polluted a lot and it
was a bad form of energy how much of
that narrative
has caused the energy crisis that we're
experiencing now that's a good question
I would say I would I would attribute
the war on nuclear to about half of the
energy crisis and the other half to the
war on natural gas if Europe had made
nuclear 70 or 80 percent of its
electricity it would definitely not be
having this problem right now instead
and that's where it was headed after
World War II so in the 1950s was
promoting nuclear to Europe Europe
needed a lot more than we did they knew
that there's basically only two choices
for them at the time which was coal or
nuclear and they knew that coal was more
polluting so they wanted to have a lot
of nuclear but then there was this war
on nuclear that started with the Baby
Boomers they were working out the the
psychological trauma of their fears of
nuclear weapons to some extent but then
there were also just people that were
bad actors who were also just
manipulating those fears because they
are
anti-civilization people they're against
modern civilization they're against
modern capitalism modern liberal
democracy they want to return to to some
period in the past like when when
everyone was dying of bacterial
infections like when was this period
yeah I mean it's not rational right I
mean it's Rousseau it's this idea that
things were better in the past before we
had so much inequality you know
certainly the stuff that you're you and
your dad you know talk a lot about so
it's this kind of Rousseau and desire to
return to a period before it's nostalgic
it's sort of the mentality of coddle to
people you know it's sort of like why
you know like I think about a child I
think you're a mother right Michaela
yeah five-year-old okay yeah so when you
I always think it was like you know you
think of you you said you're a child you
know you can have mac and cheese or a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich and the
kid goes I don't want either of those
I'm not going to eat them the proper
response is to say okay you don't have
to eat yeah you know the the wrong
response is to say oh well we'll try to
find some other thing you know whatever
I'll make you something else well it's
in that constant idea that somehow you
don't have to make choices that you can
you know that really the choices were
the choices for energy Security in
Europe were Frack for natural gas burn
more coal or have more nuclear well they
said they didn't want that so they just
imported all this gas from Russia
imagining that there would be no
consequence that there was a serious
consequence how is importing natural gas
better for the climate than using
natural gas that isn't imported from
Russia what difference does it make
where it's from not much uh piped
natural gas has somewhat less carbon
emissions because it's just coming you
don't have to ship it on a ship which
requires the diesel to run the ship or
you don't have to use energy to convert
it from into liquid and then and then
re-gasify it so just one way to think of
it is that every time you add an energy
conversion you're both adding cost and
adding environmental some amount of
environmental degradation so an energy
conversion is just turning something
from a gas into a liquid or taking
electricity and putting it into a
chemical battery or from a chemical
battery to electricity this is why in
general what you want is is very few
energy conver versions and you want the
cleanest form of energy high up the
energy ladder so wooden dung are the
dirtiest coal is cleaner than wooden
dung gas is half the carbon emissions
and you know a small fraction of the air
pollution and then uranium is the
cleanness your nuclear is the cleanest
form of energy because it doesn't emit
any pollution or any waste products into
the natural environment huh okay so
let's talk more about these I think you
said solar panels and wind turbines from
China yeah some of the wind turbines are
produced in Europe but a lot of the
materials are processed in China China
dominates the production of what are
called Rare Earth minerals
most of the minerals that are required
for using Renewables are processed in
China it's uh lithium copper
you know rare Earths uh so it what
you're doing if you're trying to use
less oil and gas in the United States or
in Canada or in Europe and you're going
to then go try to use more solar and
wind you're just going to shift your
dependency from Russia to China there is
talk of bringing those Industries back
to the United States but I don't think
anybody thinks that you'll be able to be
able to make solar panels at the same
low price that they can in China
particularly since the solar panels are
being made by Major Muslims who are in
concentration camps in China is that
what Europe shows is that you need to be
energy if not energy independent you
need to be energy secure so Europe
either needs to burn coal
now it needs to frac for natural gas or
needs to do a lot more nuclear power
naturally the leaders who created the
crisis in the first place are not doing
those things and they're proposing to
just shift their dependency from Russia
to China in terms of going from natural
gas to Renewables you'd think not
relying on Russia or China would be the
best option
the intuitive sense is the correct one
yes
so you said there are people in
concentration camps in China who are
making the solar panels which should be
okay so then
the fact that's something right
that's so bad so by is that all solar
panels is that solar panels in America
too if you buy a solar panel can you oh
my yeah like 90 like 90 of the solar
panels that you get if you go down to
Home Depot or if they come in and put
them on your roof that's yeah that's
what you're buying that's why
and this is a this is not by the way
this is the U.S state Department it's
the German bundish dog it's BBC there's
not any debate that these solar panels
are being made in those conditions I
myself I just testified in front of
Congress about a week ago and I was
Raising this issue and I was and I and I
keep raising it with people because it's
kind of like what are we doing here like
how do we how are we justifying this the
bite Administration said it was going to
stop importing the solar panels and then
it just
it just got lobbied by the solar
industry and just dropped it and it was
like well we'll just keep importing
solar panels like kind of no explanation
no moral justification
for me
it's really uh like a horror movie you
know it's like yeah you kind of the
horror movies they open with you see the
solar panels on your roof you think
they're clean you think they're green
they're kind of magic and then the more
you learn about it you get to that
middle part of the horror movie and you
realize they're being made by people
that are basically been enslaved and are
living in concentration camps and
working in solar factories is is really
the only work they're allowed to have
so it's pretty horrible
there's no way to sugarcoat it for me
it's like
I just sometimes I just it's one of the
issues that I just kind of Despair a
little bit over because it's it's very
dark when you realize especially when
you kind of people spend have said for
decades that we were you know gonna say
no to genocide like genocide was not
something that the West Was going to
tolerate that's obviously not the case
because not only are we tolerating that
we're actually financing it whenever we
buy solar panels and lithium batteries
too by the way they're all sourced from
Province
yeah let me say something else about it
my some of my some of my friends they
say well what about your iPhone your
iPhone's made yeah in China too there's
a difference between products that are
made in Guangzhou Province in China
which is where your iPhones are made and
solar panels and batteries that are made
in xinjiang Province Guangzhou Province
yeah I mean it's not great it's still
China there's still facial recognition
and creepy you know social points uh you
know totalitarianism but that's not the
same as being rounded up and put in a
concentration camp there's a qualitative
difference there and I think it's
important to recognize that difference
so you could say well maybe we want to
we want less dependence on China overall
but we should not be importing any solar
panels from China at this point I I had
heard about the solar panel I didn't
realize it it was all the solar panels
basically is there anyone else who makes
solar panels there are there are some
firms there's actually a firm in
California that does they just can't
compete in terms of cost of course yeah
but you said lithium batteries as well
so does that what do you mean and what
how do you avoid those what are those in
is that all lithium batteries it's not
totally clear the best report actually
was done by the New York Times for their
credit I criticized them a lot on the
stuff but they actually did a really
good it just came out the big report
about lithium batteries not totally
clear
um so we're not totally sure we do know
that the raw materials for solar poly
silicon over 90 of it comes from
xinjiang Province in China so even
places that might be making solar panels
outside of xinjiang Province are still
using the main ingredients and I believe
it's the same thing with lithium so that
the refining of the lithium is done in
xinjiang Province but it's probably it
could very well be a fair amount of it
as well
a lot of the companies that make these
products quite understandably try to
keep it secret where they're
manufacturing facilities are in part
because they don't want the scrutiny on
human rights and environmental issues
this is crazy so people are going to die
in Europe because energy is too
expensive because
governments in Europe have been funding
concentration camps in China
basically that simplifies it but
basically wow yeah and refusing and
refusing I think at the more if you want
to get to kind of the psychology of it I
think refusing to take responsibility
for producing their own energy and sort
of behaving like consumers I think we're
so used to being able to kind of buy
whatever we want from other people
particularly from China that there isn't
a sense in which energy is sort of
different it's an important industrial
activity it's like farming it's like
producing steel you need to actually do
it in your home country precisely
because it's so important I mean there's
a set of folks including some pretty
otherwise very intelligent economists
who kind of look at energy like it's
some other commodity you know apples and
bananas and cement and energy it's like
well no but energy is different because
everything depends on energy so if you
have an energy crisis it affects every
single sector of the economy
particularly the heavy Industries that
in places like Germany are how they are
wealthy the reason Germany is the
wealthiest most powerful country in
Europe
is because it has so much cheap energy
to support its Industries uh yikes
interesting so there was too much virtue
signaling basically
from from Europe being like yeah we're
at the Forefront we're going to be we're
going to be the green people and now
people are going to freeze wow that's
terrible so yeah it's too much virtue
signaling and also not enough
in the sense that I wish there had been
virtue signaling about the treatment of
weaker Muslims and Chinese store
factories it's more like um it's also
the ways in which you know we become so
ideological and we've become so
um disconnected I mean uh Karl Marx of
all people had a really brilliant
chapter in his book Capital where he
talked about something called commodity
fetishism
and what he meant by that is that you
know in the olden times you used to know
the guy that made your shoes where the
guy who made your beef well now the with
under capitalism Supply chains are so
disconnected that you don't know the
people that made the things that you use
and so those products end up taking on a
kind of they end up taking on a kind of
Life at their own that's what the fetish
is in other words you sort of see the
iPhone but I use my iPhone I have a
relationship with my iPhone but I never
think about the people that made it I
never think about the working conditions
and so it's actually got gotten worse
than that it's not just you don't think
about it but you actually look at the
solar panels and you think that you're
saving the world you don't think that
you're contributing to genocide in China
and so it's really this deep
disconnection
by a lot of people but particularly
Progressive Elites because they're the
most disconnected from the productive
sectors of the economy when you talk to
the working people people who work in
manufacturing farming energy they're
much more skeptical of the things that
people claim about things like climate
change or energy or oh Farmers should
just use organic fertilizer people that
are in the productive sectors of the
economy are much more skeptical and much
more likely to say that's not actually
true because I know how you produce food
I know how you produce steel I know how
you make products and it's not like that
so I think that's part of the problem is
that those of us that are that are kind
of you know what we call anywhere people
where the where the global Elites we fly
on airplanes we never get our hands
dirty we're the ones that actually
um are they're the ones that are the
most kind of delusional apocalyptic
about climate change and also least
realistic about what it takes to power a
modern economy this kind of sounds
similar to people who are saying well
shut down the beef industry but they're
not looking at well regenerative farms
for instance and what that looks like
they're just saying well everyone should
go plant-based it's like well what is
that going to do exactly yeah the same
thing is happening in the Netherlands
right now so I've been writing some
stories about the Netherlands the
farmers are actually reduced nitrogen
pollution which mostly comes from manure
through basic Farm practices and some
amount of technological innovation but
for example if you clean your barn
stalls and you don't allow them to
manure if you collect the manure rather
than letting it kind of run off or the
liquids coming out and the liquids
contain all the nitrogen runoff if you
just maintain your farm you can reduce
the nitrogen pollution by a significant
amount they're already reduced it by 40
percent the government instead of
promoting those techniques the
government has basically said we need to
have less livestock farming we just need
to have less cattle and it's crazy
because you can actually significantly
reduce pollution of all kinds I mean you
know in in the United States and Canada
really in all wealthy countries we've
massively reduced air pollution you
might see these old photos from like the
1940s where there was like smoke in the
streets the cars were so dirty I mean I
just the other day I had a car pass by
that held the smoke coming out of its
exhaust yeah that's crazy you know yeah
so things have changed you know so we're
able to do so much with technological
innovation and when people are saying no
you should just use less energy you
should stop driving or you should not
have any cows or livestock you knew that
there's an alternative agenda going on
but it's not really about reducing
pollution it's using pollution as an
excuse to Advocate what is fundamentally
an anti-civilization agenda
okay so that is what's going on I mean
that's what my dad says instead it
sounds pretty you've got a spot on out
there that issue yeah well I mean it
looks like it one of the things he
taught me that I I really like is if you
can't figure out the reason somebody's
doing something look at the consequences
right of their behaviors yeah yeah and
then and for the Cause right so so you
yeah so you go so we don't know why
they're advocating Renewables and
shutting down the nuclear plants well
look at the energy crisis which is a
crisis of civilization it's a crisis
that will result in people becoming
poorer and de-industrializing
now it's interesting in this case of
course
um we did know what they were doing
because every Green Party in the world
has been attacking industrialization
demonizing industrialization I mean
listen to the way you know progressives
and greens talk about
industrialization they make it sound
like a bad word like somehow like life
before industry was hunky dory as
opposed to being deeply brutal
you know where women were subjugated to
lives on the farm where kids were
working on farms all the time life was
hard and dark and so so yeah the the
attack on industrialization is really an
attack on Modern civilization on the
prosperity and the wealth and the
freedom that they allow that it allows
are companies already moving to the
States you said you thought companies
like steel manufacturers are going to be
moving to the states is that already
happening
to some extent it is yes we saw when
natural gas prices in the United States
became very cheap starting around 2010
as a result of the fracking Revolution
then you started to see fertilizer
companies in particular come back what
we've seen in manufacturing uh come back
including coming back from places like
China which is really great wow that
yeah if you think that the United States
and North America and Western liberal
democracies are are significantly better
at a moral level than China's
totalitarian regime this is great news
so what it means is that you want energy
to be cheap not expensive it makes
countries more secure it it makes us
competitive with our Rivals and I think
the other thing is that you saw in terms
of natural gas I don't think I mentioned
it but it's important to know that we
reduced our carbon emissions in the
United States by 22 between 2005 and
2020. wow most of that reduction was by
having cheap abundant natural gas to
replace dirtier coal okay one thing you
mentioned and I'm just thinking about
the ramifications you said rare earth
metals that China controls most of the
rare earth metals in that those are in
our phones so
that also seems Seems like an issue not
exactly an energy issue but does that
mean if if something happens between you
know China and America relations that
our phones are in Jeopardy well it's not
it's the phones it's the solar panels
it's the
um it's the wind turbines it's the
batteries
um and it and by the way rare Earths uh
is a set of minerals they're not super
they're very or materials they're super
um they're just very dilute uh in the
Earth's surface so you just have to mine
a lot of it in order to generate
sufficient quantities of it and you're
going to need a lot more of those
those materials and metals if you're
going to move to Renewables so that's
the problem with it I think each of the
exact statistics but basically
um
the the amount of those materials that
you need if you're going to use uh you
know if you're going to you if you're
going to use Renewables is so much
higher so just to give you a sense of it
solar and wind require 300 percent more
copper 700 more rare Earths
the natural gas per unit of energy a
thousand percent more steel concrete and
glass
four thousand two hundred percent more
two thousand five hundred percent more
graphite and so this is a problem
because the way to think about the way
to think about nature protection is that
you want to use less of it if you want
to save nature then don't use it in your
put it in your phones or in your
products
and so you what you want is a reduced
material intensity or what we call you
want dematerialization and to some
extent things like your phones are very
important to that because the phone
replaces your old stereo console systems
cameras yeah television sets newspapers
books alarm clocks like so many things
you can imagine that used to be that
your phone now replaces so your phone is
dematerializing
all sorts of of products but then energy
also has a process of dematerialization
so when you go from coal think about
when you go from coal to Natural Gas
you're reducing the amount of the earth
that you're using for energy you're
actually just pulling a gas out of the
ground it's already radically
dematerialized or in the case of nuclear
a single Coke can of uranium can provide
me with all the power I need for my
entire life it's a tiny amount of the
Earth
so anybody who loves nature who wants to
protect nature should want to use less
of it and that means that you want to
use more energy dense and less material
intensive fuels so going from natural
gas or nuclear to solar panels and wind
turbines
and electric cars for that matter means
you're just going to use much more of of
Nature and create these huge frankly
toxic and polluting mines and all the
waste that's associated with them around
the world yeah okay that's crazy so they
haven't taken into consideration the
mining required for those materials to
make these renewable energy sources like
solar panels that's not taken into
consideration
well they well this is a very important
point so for decades people have been
making this point finally the
International Energy agency which is the
uh which is the kind of big energy think
tank for Rich and developed countries
the oecd countries they came out with a
report last year just that provided all
those numbers that I just rattled off
pointing out saying well to make this
energy transition which everyone thinks
we're going to make you're going to have
to increase the materials so the amount
of materials per unit of energy is going
to have to go from somewhere around 10
percent to somewhere around 50 percent
this is an agency that by the way is
completely promoting Renewables and so
they kind of said this like well this is
just something that's going to have to
happen as opposed to like wait a second
is that something that we want to have
happen
because the alternative is that you
could just use more natural gas and
uranium and not have to increase the
material intensity of energy the other
important thing about this is that
environmental product the good news is
that economic progress and environmental
progress go hand in hand so if you're
using less materials for energy copper
Rare Earth steel zinc all those things
then you are going to have a lower cost
so if you're using more materials it's
going to raise the cost of energy it's
going to be more material intensive and
so Renewables make a make energy much
more expensive in multiple ways there's
more materials required much more land
three to six hundred times more land for
solar or wind farms than for a nuclear
natural gas plant and then the
unreliable nature of the electricity the
wind is a particular super random the
way it comes into the grid and then
stops blowing and it's just wind right
or even solar like the sun sets you know
at around the same time of day that
people start using a lot of energy
managing all of that unreliability
increases the cost of energy so we're
really
um Renewables which were sort of this
romantic way to return to the Past are
actually a way of or in that sense that
we were talking about in terms of if you
don't know the the motivations of
somebody they are a way of undermining
civilization which depends on cheap and
reliable energy
that's wild things are so much more
complicated than we're told
okay for for storing renewable energy
what kind of batteries is renewable
energy stored in
so it's overwhelmingly I mean basically
the only way to store large amounts of
energy from an electrical grid is what
we call pumped storage which is that you
pump the water uphill when you have a
lot of electricity like in a dam and
then you run the water back over a
turbine when you need it there's a
nuclear plant in California that had
that built this pumped Hydro System uh
near it you know or along with it in
California so that when the when you had
increases in demand because of course
the demand during the day Rises at
certain times of the day you're able to
have this pump storage facility everyone
has gotten excited about lithium
batteries the same thing that's in your
phone but the problem is they're super
expensive so it's about a half a
trillion dollars for just four hours of
backing up the Grid in the United States
the batteries have yeah it's it's just
financially impossible California has
been spending more money on batteries
than anybody else in the really in the
world certainly in the United States
and we did not have enough batteries
that would allow us to shut down our
natural gas plants or shut down our last
nuclear plant which is why the governor
and part of the reason why the
government in California kept our last
nuclear plant operating decided to so we
almost had blackouts again a few weeks
ago proving that even a huge investment
in batteries was just not enough to be
able to back up a state the size of
California
is it true that the governor of
California at some point told people to
stop charging their Teslas
yeah well so what happened was on August
20
25th the state announced that they were
going to phase out internal combustion
engines gasoline-powered engines okay
guessing powered cars by 2030. five days
later the the government said don't
charge your electric cars between four
and nine PM otherwise we're going to
have blackouts so we're clearly not
prepared for being able to have all
these cars via electric just to give you
a sense of it the using the the numbers
provided by the state we I calculated
that you would need 10 full-sized new
nuclear power plants in addition to the
one that we have right now in order to
just charge the 30 million cars and like
trucks that you would that you would
have if you completely transferred to
electric cars and trucks the other thing
that they're doing and again I think
this speaks to the irrationality and the
nihilism they're phasing out the sale of
of natural gas heaters in California and
furnaces in California in 20
30 so you won't be able to buy a natural
gas heater for your home after 20 30.
yeah there's a replacement or for a new
home well so that means that you're
going to have to have an electric heater
and again you're gonna have this huge
crisis they're also been planning to
shut down our last nuclear plant one
year before then so
It's a combination of people are not
thinking it through but then also a
combination of people they don't care
like there's some part of them that you
know as Michael Cain says to Batman they
just want to see the whole world burn
and there are actually there's some part
of them I think that wants to see the
chaos and the crisis because they think
it's going to get us closer to returning
to some state of nature so you don't
think that these are just people who
aren't paying attention I have this view
of the world and it's slowly burning but
my I guess previous view of the world
was that big mistakes like this were
made by people who were really trying to
improve things really trying to improve
things and they're saying well that
doesn't matter but the bigger goal is
going to be such a great future that it
it doesn't matter right and you're
saying well no there are people who are
like wow just let the let the world burn
and they're at the like top tier
government level making decisions like
let's shut down all the nuclear power
plants yeah for sure I mean it's it's a
little bit of both and sometimes in the
same person I mean think about how
sometimes when we're in a bad mood or
when when we're
um annoyed at something I we all do it
and I see I see people say it kind of
goes I hear it from people like
conservatives about Europe it kind of
goes let them suffer
it kind of goes they let them deal with
the consequences of this well that same
thing on the left says well you should
why should you be able to use
electricity whenever you want
what makes you think that you should
have cheap energy cheap electricity and
energy the world can't afford to have
that nature can't afford for you to be
such a privileged entitled consumer
um you spoiled you know rich person you
should have to do with less because
nature wants you to have less
and then in a like a few hours later or
when they have to talk publicly they'll
say something like
well it'll make us all happier because
um you know we'll work together to deal
with these challenges and you know
money's not everything and what about
nature so you know it's always a
combination of both that it's like you
know it's like it's classic
um
dark some of it's dark Triad stuff you
know where there's a kind of which is
what narcissism machiavellianism and
sociopathy there's some amount of it
which is sort of like
um
Kathy Bates and the movie Misery you
know which is like I'm gonna take care
of you yeah and it's like hey God no
please don't you know
how is fertilizer all wrapped up in this
and why is fertilizer so necessary yeah
well so there's there's three kinds of
fertilizer
um uh phosphate potash and and nitrogen
and so nitrogen fertilizer
is made from natural gas and so uh
fertilizer okay is yeah so surf so
fertilizer is
um is is
uh nitrogen fixed nitrogen basically
taking the nitrogen gas and turning it
into
a solid that can be applied so Miracle
Grow that you go you put in your garden
so you put on oh that's cool
so that is made from
natural gas natural gas is CH4 so
there's four hydrogen atoms bonded to a
carbon atom and so if you split the
hydrogen atoms off and you fix them you
make them into a solid then that's how
you get fertilizer so if you have a
shortage of gas then you have a shortage
of fertilizer why is that essential for
modern food production and is that
contributing to the food production
crisis we're also seeing for sure yeah I
mean so Europe's because of high energy
prices uh fertilizer production has
declined between 70 to 80 percent that's
catastrophic I mean it's extremely scary
and dangerous
and wow yeah so it's
um it's scary it's bad
um I'm sorry what was the oh if you
don't I mean just the rule of thumb is
that if we didn't have fertilizers we
would be able to produce just about half
as much food as we produce now so that
means that we would have only enough uh
food for four billion people not for 8
billion people
so you may know you know
um that there's a very dark view that
some environmentalists have which is
that the Earth should not be able to
sustain this amendment yeah there's been
a philosophy going back a couple hundred
years that that mass famines are
inevitable but it's creepier than that
because the people that claim that it's
inevitable to have mass famine are the
ones that are trying to reduce the
amount of fertilizer that gets produced
so they're kind of trying to create not
kind of they're they're creating a
self-fulfilling prophecy
um around fertilizer reductions and so
we just saw in Sri Lanka
the government under the advice of a lot
of Western environmentalists said well
we're going to just ban synthetic
fertilizer and the result was
crash of you know just they couldn't
produce enough food for their people and
the whole economy crashed and ended up
bringing down the government
what are your forecasts for the next
year I suppose in Europe like are they
in trouble not just for a like a very
cold winter but also for food shortages
like really places in Europe are
yeah I mean as usual the people that
will suffer the most are the poor both
in Europe and around the world so Europe
because it's Rich it's going to end up
buying a lot of the liquefied natural
gas that the world produces and
therefore countries like Pakistan and
Bangladesh won't be able to afford as
much of that same thing with fertilizer
and food so you'll see the you know so
it's like the crises will occur in
places like Haiti sub-Saharan Africa
poor Asian countries
Europeans
are going to
like they're not going to starve and
they're probably not going to freeze to
death but they're gonna but the Germans
are almost certainly going to lose a
bunch of their heavy Industries so
they're just going to become a lot
poorer and that's going to occur not
just now but over several years over the
next three to five years things are
going to be bad because that's how long
it's going to take to significantly
increase energy production either from
natural gas or from from nuclear or from
coal
and by then they're going to have lost a
bunch of Industries and some Industries
are just going to be like hey we're out
of here we're going to go and relocate
into the United States or into some
other country where there's or Canada
where there's cheap and reliable energy
so that's the that's the concern I think
on a more optimistic note
you know this is clearly a cycle you
know we go through civilization goes
through cycles and this is clearly a
crisis where
a lot of people just forgot what it
takes to run a civilization like you
said I mean like we were talking about
like most ordinary ordinary
environmentalists
they just say things that they don't
even know what it means oh we can power
the world 100 Renewables or oh we can
use Organics and they have no idea what
that means and so what's happening is
that people are having to deal with the
consequences of their choices that were
made in most cases out of misinformation
but also out of ideology
and I think that it's going to be a
heavy wake-up call you know my my
favorite slogan or out of a slogan my
favorite saying these days is
Good Times make weak leaders weak
leaders make bad times and bad times
make strong leaders strong leaders make
good times
um
I think that's the cycle that we're in
we've got a bunch of like leaders in
power
where they're just doing everything
they're doing like literally in Europe
they're like we're gonna just move to
Renewables faster it's like you are just
delusional so it's like everything
they're doing is actually making the
invited and Trudeau and European leaders
are basically making a crisis worse so
we're seeing a crisis
of the West it's interesting to me that
already the Japanese and the South
Koreans have moved on and so one of the
the hypotheses you know not just me with
others has been that the West is in the
grip of a religion it's very similar to
the older judeo-christian religion we've
sinned against nature Nature's a kind of
victim God nature is punishing us with
climate change the only way to make
right by nature is through Renewables
that's been the dominant ideology in the
West for the last you know 30 years but
South Korea and Japan they're like over
it they're restarting their nuclear
plants they're burning coal they don't
have that they don't have that Obsession
I think it's because
those are cultures that are in and that
have an ancestor that are focused on
ancestor myth rather than on a myth
around a victim God and so the victim
God's story which has been dominant in
the West for you know 2000 2500 years
is um really been absent so it's almost
like we have a particular Hardware that
when belief in God disappeared the new
apocalyptic environmentalism and woke is
um acted like soft like the new software
for this our kind of Hardware interests
in Asia they didn't have that they were
sort of spared that that problem and so
they're just getting on with it they're
trying to produce and they're going to
end up doing a lot better than Europe
okay that all makes sense to me
um I've had a few other people on my
podcast to talk about this and they've
brought up you know food shortages in
Europe but it does make more sense to me
that the people that would suffer would
be
would be the poor poor people that and
then that's also going to be probably
less picked up too by the media because
it's a lot more of a boring story if a
poor company has start uh poor country
has starving people than a you know you
know Germany or something like that yeah
they have to overthrow the governments
in those countries for it to really
become a big story
I mean we will have famines
um and you know of course some people
will go hungry in Europe but it just
won't be anything like it is other parts
of the world where just because the
Europeans because it's still a global
market the Europeans are going to be
able to compete with poor countries to
purchase energy and food I wanted to
talk a bit about you were you were
talking about addiction and homelessness
and so what kind of addiction have you
seen that's causing this yeah so we are
in and it's in the it's in Canada too
we're in the worst drug epidemic in
history uh there's nothing that compares
to it to give you a sense of it in the
United States 17 000 people died of drug
overdoses and Drug poisonings in the
year 2000 this year 107 000 will die so
we're gonna see a huge increase of
five-fold six-fold increase in deaths
wow that's three times more people than
die in car accidents it's five times
more people than are killed by homicides
I believe it's about three times more
than are killed but that are committed
suicide it's the number one cause of
death among people 18 to 45
it's indistinguishable from the Mental
Health crisis in the west the crisis of
anxiety and depression
there's not any evidence that serious
mental illness like schizophrenia and
bipolar disorder have increased so we're
clearly dealing with
just the worsening of anxiety and
depression which you know to some extent
everybody gets but a really a
consequence of
lack of purpose which you might call
nihilism
I think a consequence of these just
really dark dystopian and apocalyptic
ideologies
just all the stuff that you know you and
your dad are are looking into and
talking about it's just kind of depths
of Despair the drugs themselves have
gotten much harder much more
intoxicating much more addictive much
deadlier you know there's San Francisco
it's hard to find heroin it's all
fentanyl now fentanyl being 50 times
stronger than heroin
even cocaine has been displaced by
methamphetamine in the forms of
methamphetamine are even stronger and
stronger they keep finding new exotic
drugs in that contaminate the drug
supplies
things like
anti-anxiety drugs they find we're
getting various animal tranquilizers
contaminating the drug supplies
and so you have a drug epidemic and then
you have just a kind of coddling
attitude of victim ideology that
is sort of the the one of the subsects
of wokism which says to victims
everything should be given and nothing
required
and so that's how you get people like if
they're living on the street living in
their own excrement dying of drugs or
just and behaving and self-destructive
and destructive ways that's how you get
progressive City governments whether
Vancouver or San Francisco or Seattle or
Portland Los Angeles
saying oh we don't want to do you know
let them just let them be and
I mean there was a guy with
schizophrenia clearer I the guy that was
behaving in psychotic ways I'll say we
don't know if it's from schizophrenia
because it could have been from meth
since long-term methamphetamine use
results in psychotic behaviors
there's a story that went viral where he
was because the guy filmed like I was in
his car and the man on the street was
through his feces Adam in the car in the
in the SUV the guy tries to get the
police to arrest the guy and the police
wouldn't do it and the guy was like
living on the street throwing his feces
at people and and they were like well
we're not gonna arrest him
this is San Francisco or California Los
Angeles yeah Los Angeles so they finally
got all this publicity so they finally
arrested them
and we were always watching with my wife
and I was like they had this whole TV
segment on it and I was like at some I
was like how do you get to the whole TV
segment they don't talk about the fact
that like this person is suffering
mental illness or or something that
like there's a sense in which and it's
like they've made it progressives have
made it sort of taboo to even talk about
the fact that people are living on the
street because of their addiction
because of their mental illness because
they made a tattoo because they kind of
go well we don't want to stigmatize the
people on the street but as a result
the people on the street aren't getting
the help they need but obviously it's
not like the guy is throwing his feces
at somebody because he's a bad guy it's
not like he's living on the street
because he just like
couldn't afford the rent these are
consequences of untreated mental illness
and addiction and so
part of my work in writing San Francisco
and in creating you know co-founding the
California Peace Coalition which is this
Coalition of
parents of addicts recovered addicts
you know residents and others is to just
kind of go look we're this is obviously
a problem of addiction and untreated
mental illness and we've got to stop
treating it like a housing problem we
definitely need more housing we need
more housing everywhere but that's not
why people go live and sleep on
cardboard or intents on the street and
smoke fentanyl all day they're there
because they're drug habits or their
psychosis has led them to to stop
working alienate themselves from friends
and family
and live on the streets and there's been
a kind of denial about it even more
Darkly I would say there's progressives
that have used these people to advance a
completely alt you know ulterior agenda
around
subsidized housing I supported some
amount of subsidized housing I'm not
even against you know certainly for
people that suffer mental illness they
need to be in subsidized housing
but you can't let people live on the
street we now know that three times more
people who are homeless die if they live
on the street than if they're in
shelters and they die because they're
run over by cars they're murdered and
they die from drug overdoses so there's
absolutely it's it's cruel not
compassionate to let people live on the
street
so those two things you see homelessness
and drugs are
overlapping problems they're not exactly
the same but it's the drug problem and
the interest illness problem that's
driving what we call homelessness are
there more drugs available now is that
what happened did the drugs come first
or do you think they're or do you think
the need for them because of the rising
anxiety Rising depression did that come
first and now the drugs are there yeah I
mean there's definitely more demand and
there's definitely more Supply and
they're definitely more addictive and
more deadly like all three things are
true I mean I'm very interested in
Europe because Europe it has this energy
crisis but it doesn't have the drug
crisis like they're not having these
drug overdose deaths in Netherlands or
Portugal little increase in homelessness
that you see but a lot of that is from
refugees
or you know immigrants
um and it's nothing like we have in
places like Vancouver San Francisco Los
Angeles Seattle Portland
and so I'm interested in what they've
done in Europe I mean a they have a
proper psychiatric and addiction care
system
they also don't give out drugs the same
way they do in America like if you just
compare the dosing too for an
anti-anxiety medication or an
antidepressant in America it's it's way
higher than what they're allowed to do
in Europe which is very strange
absolutely I mean I they never had the
opioid over the prescription opioid
crisis like we had and when you ask them
about it it's because
they they had much more of an attitude
of like
you know like like just just not
prescribing that much you know when I
went and I had an appendectomy
a couple years ago
or not I guess I had it last year and
they they were like here you can take
these opioids you know there's a
prescription that they were gonna be
different to me and I was like do I need
them
and they're like well you may not but
we're gonna give it to you anyway and I
said well why don't you just wait until
the Advil stops working
this is much more of that here than in
Europe in Europe they're much stricter
with it and they're just much stricter
on all of these things so I think that
matters I also think though that
families are more intact in Europe
there's just people live closer to their
families like if you're Dutch yeah
people can move and work all over Europe
but like
like I live in California like
people that are not from California our
families are hundreds or thousands of
miles away yeah and so Europe and Canada
we're so spread out that you have a
normal normal amounts of family
disaffiliation that are much higher and
family disaffiliation or alienation from
friends and family is just one of the
key risk factors for drug addiction so I
think all of those things come in into
the play in terms of why things got so
bad here I think also um doctors aren't
taught directly by pharmaceutical
Representatives like they are in the U.S
in Europe
pharmaceutical companies which we should
have
yeah interesting I like that family I I
didn't think about that the way that
families are structured in Europe that
if you have a bunch of people around you
and then you start having a hard time
with drugs you have a bunch of people
siblings cousin aunt and uncle that are
all like what are you doing turn things
around right now yeah yeah that's sad
and they sort of in Portugal's most
famous but they sort of they sort of
when they're dealing with someone that's
an addict they get the they have a they
stage interventions with government
officials so like you have family
members plus like government social
workers plus like a judge
or police that are all like hey you
gotta quit you gotta knock this stuff
off and there's pressure put on you
it's it's a really great model I don't
know if it would work here you know
we're very libertarian
particularly in the United States but I
suspect North America overall like
people are very sensitive about not
um saying anything about not having
interventions unless it's really out of
control we're very hands off and and
there's a lot of stigma
and the stigma is sort of related to so
you kind of get people that are like it
actually works in these really funny
ways where people are like they're both
embarrassed by it and they don't want to
deal with it and so then that's why you
end up getting people living on the
street or overdosing is that
basically family and friends have kind
of they don't want to deal with it they
don't want to take up responsibility
yeah wow and when they try to I've you
know I've had three friends from high
school that became
uh homeless drug addicts and two are
dead and the families struggle you know
because they don't like on the one hand
like you're you're your child is like
stealing from you to maintain his or her
drug habit
so do you cut them off knowing that
they're going to end up on the street
and engaged in sex work or theft to
maintain their habit or do you let them
stay at home where they're going to be
constantly stealing from you and doing
drugs in the house
it's not an easy decision to make and
you need to have
a societal response you need to not
allow people because of their drug habit
to go be homeless you just don't allow
people that are sick with
substance use disorder which is the
politically correct term for for drug
addiction you should not let people
because they're sick live on the street
and turn to prostitution or theft in
order to maintain their habit the police
should intervene yeah mandate that
people get the medical care they need
it's just a strange psychiatric illness
and that it's a psychiatric disorder I
should say that requires law enforcement
there's not many other forms of
psychiatric there's not many other forms
of
of psychiatric you know problems that
require the law the law to get involved
but in the case of addiction it is
required I think it I Think It's Tricky
too I'm wondering if America and Canada
for that matter has more of an issue
like you said because we had the opioid
crisis so a bunch of people ended up on
on opiates
um but psych meds as well because we're
one of the most over-medicated or just
medicated countries I think probably the
most in the entire world in regards to
psych medications and some of those are
literally
um I was I was on an antidepressant from
the age of 12 to 23. getting off of that
I didn't know it was addictive getting
off of that almost killed me like really
it was and I've like
which I was not something I was prepared
for I wasn't aware that it was causing
dependency issues
and so I don't know what kind of role
that has to play
with just over medication of an entire
population huge of course it does now
the good news is that your region of
Alberta which is like the Texas of
Canada
has experienced a
uh is that fair
yeah yeah totally fair
um has seen a decline in opioid related
deaths by by half in July of this year
compared to its peak and the reason is
is because they have started to move
more towards this Dutch
model of interesting pressure on addicts
to quit they've abandoned the kind of
radical harm reduction model
so the good news is that we know we know
it works because you can just look at
the Netherlands or Portugal or Alberta
now and see that there's a solutions to
it so I always agree yeah for sure
there's all these definitely risk
factors in the United States we're
really quick to I mean look at like
hyperactivity
um yeah I've I've increasingly of the
view that there's just a number of
of you have a bunch of I mean I hate to
call them psychiatric but you have a
bunch of psychological disorders that
result in people not getting enough
exercise
you know like you go hyperactivity well
that's a child that hasn't had enough
exercise yeah yeah even you know for me
anxiety is just I need to go for a run
like so when do we kind of go
why is our response to like anxiety
always there has to be a medicine for
this a drug why can't it be
because I'm a high energy person so I
think there's a lot of people that are
like high energy people that experience
anxiety well that's just because you're
not you're not properly managing you
know you're not probably you know and
then there's a CBT and there's all these
other things that you can do so for sure
for sure
our propensity our quickness into
seeking a drug response is part of the
problem
yeah and I I have some experience with
the medical system in in Europe and I do
know that if you go to the doctor and
you're like I'm suffering from
depression I'm anxious I'm too anxious
to work a lot of the times the doctors
there will say well are you exercising
what's your family like are you eating
okay like go home and lose like loose
and they're just rougher right lose some
weight like they're they're harsh right
they're not just like well here's a pill
to fix you right yeah it's different
there it's interesting I'm inclined to
think that it's because
pharmaceutical representatives were
educating doctors compared to Europe
definitely it's part of it I mean
there's so many different things going
on right you know there's it's a
libertarianism too there's a sense in
which it's somehow like too coercive to
tell people how to change their
behaviors like it's less coercive to
give them a pill than to tell them to
just be like hey have you thought about
changing your diet or exercising more
well it's lessons it feels moralizing
yeah oh for sure it's less insulting
it's like oh you might have a chemical
imbalance that's really unfortunate
here's a fix that's way less insulting
than like there's something you might
not know that you're doing wrong right
but I mean it could be framed in a
different way you know like we've been
taught things wrong but here are some
things I've seen that help other people
you could try those first like you don't
have to be moralizing when you tell
people to exercise more
but yeah that's like a level of
complexity and doctor's appointments are
short and training yeah yeah I agree
um I think there are ways to
to do in ways that don't have to be
insulting or be perceived as a criticism
yeah I mean
um
yeah I like the way you said that some
people have really benefited from
exercising and not eating carbs yeah
would you give it a shot
yeah why don't we try that for a month
before we
you know why don't we try it for a month
before and
yeah I mean there's just yeah that's
also why you need to you need a proper
and then if you have a proper system
then you have standards of care so that
if some a mom brings in her hyperactive
child
there's some standards where you're not
going to just go give that kid a ritalin
like you're gonna get you're gonna be
like I'd like to see little Jimmy
you know getting a run in during the
morning and that we kind of reduce the
sugar he's he's consuming all day long
and see what we get to with that yeah
maybe only lasts or something yeah I
think it'll change what do you think I
think there's enough especially with
social media I think there's enough kick
back to some of these things that I
think I think a new generation needs to
come in and then things will improve I
don't see this going downhill forever
it's already at a bitter a pretty bad
place with number of people on
medications and overall health of the
society I can't see it going that I
think it's I'm hoping it's already kind
of reversing I hope so I think your dad
you and your dad have done a real
service to this issue I mean I think
that there's a lot of attention kind of
sensationalism around your lion diet
but I think that
um I know for me it's made a huge
difference to reduce my carb intake and
in fact it's still a struggle I quit
drinking
uh four years ago
and it was comparatively easy to
managing my diet in part because you
have to eat you don't have to drink
alcohol but I think that this thing of
of and I love carbs I mean of course
like yeah me too so good like oh my God
bread and like I just I can go like but
it's like I was just like I was watching
Joe Rogan too on a Saturday where it's
like he was describing just eating bread
just knocks them out and you turn 50.
yeah as I have and you're kind of like I
can't believe how how like and how just
hammered I get eating bread
you know and so there's things that you
guys have intervened in on the culture
that I think is super important and you
know the importance of CBT
is huge the importance of talking back
to yourself and that you're not just a
single self and you've got these other
voices and and it's not crazy to have to
listen to your wiser voice you can
internalize these voices for me exercise
has been massive been watching Andrew
huberman taking suggestions from him
he's great
you know like
um I'm not I'm not I haven't been as
good about lately but just a run a hard
run first thing in the morning but
exercise actually twice a day
so these things I think absolutely I
totally agree I think that they are
going to make a big difference because
the medical establishment has been
frankly just downright irresponsible
with with its its dietary
recommendations that's lack of
evangelism on exercise
I mean exercise is like it also changes
what you can eat right if you get a
really hard workout in this is true I
know I'm wondering uh I mean I'm
completely carbon tolerant completely
but I'm wondering how much of the carbon
tolerance that I think we're seeing in a
lot of people I think you can kind of
look at people and be like well they
shouldn't be eating carbs uh I wonder
how much of that is but like really and
like some people more than others
um I wonder how much of that is
by lack of exercise like maybe because
Society stopped exercising hard because
I know you see I see these people on on
Instagram in particular like serious
athletes at the gym and like maybe some
of them are on steroids but maybe some
of them aren't and they're eating carbs
and I'm like
I don't even understand how that person
exists because of how I feel when I eat
them but I mean they're exercising
constantly and people did used to like
walk you know even if they had an office
job they did something right there
wasn't a gym but that's because they
actually did things I was like I wonder
how much of the carb intolerance is from
just Society exercising less too I mean
I notice it just when I've stopped um I
I we give up our office which I had to
you know drive and walk slightly to but
I even noticed it just that just
eliminating the commute I think a bunch
of people will also during covet they
eliminate the commute they work from
home it's just it's not it doesn't have
to be a lot of calories for it to make a
difference you know yeah but certainly
like a hard workout I've gotten to the
point too where it's like you can have
like a really hard workout and go too
far and be like okay my body does need
some amount of carbs you know but like
oh for sure it is you know plus Karma's
are so cheap and yeah they're everywhere
and they're so immediately gratifying in
a way that proteins
can be but are not quite
so oh yeah for sure no I was reading I
mean you need to take holes you know and
Gary Tobbs and and the whole Atkins
movement was on to this
years ago but I think that that was
always framed as a kind of weight loss
issue it then became kind of a health
issue but now I just think I think it's
the work you and your father have done
that's so important is you guys have
helped to highlight and for me
personally it's been a big thing
highlighted the ways in which is also a
mental health issue that actually is
thinking like if I eat too many carbs
like I just don't think right yeah it'd
have to be a little I like to be a
little hungry when I'm riding or working
because it actually you get some of that
mental Clarity well I hope so I hope so
I mean the reason I got into diet mainly
was uh because of my mental health it
was just a complete disaster and I
couldn't stand it like I can't not think
I've got things to do yeah I mean that
was so much of stoicism is about the
body
you know and it's about the mind and the
Brain and we don't think of it this way
but obviously like the brain is a is an
organ
you know the brain is a physical yeah
physical organ and like there's no sense
in being you know your your this bod
this is part of your this is part of
your body and so you've got to keep fit
the fitness affects the whole body and
then I also think that that's also this
is some of the nice contribution from
Buddhism is that right thinking is
important it's important to get your
thoughts right and to talk back to the
negative thoughts of that CBT so you can
kind of sort of see a picture
that I think has come out of both you
and your father but then obviously
people like Joe Rogan and Andrew
huberman and these other important
figures
um
I like this young stoic guy with his
name Ryan
he's got a new book God I'm going to
read um Ryan
holiday
Ryan holiday yeah yeah where you kind of
get a picture of you know discipline in
terms of schedule and daytime routine
eating exercise but then thinking and
that these things are all working
together for optimal physical and mental
health and that we should think about
those things holistically yeah I I agree
with that I was thinking what exactly it
was that set me on kind of a health
journey and it was it was desperation
not to die from an autoimmune disorder
but it was also something I don't know
if it was the age I got to or how I was
raised or what but something changed in
that I decided it was really I stopped I
decided to stop being a victim and I
never really felt sorry for myself like
having an autoimmune disorder I never
had self-pity but I did take kind of my
own agency away so when I went to the
doctor and and I was told there's
nothing you can do about it
I believed that and that belief was
hindering my ability to heal and so at
some point I think I went through the
medical system to a point where I just
didn't get help anywhere and I went to
everyone and no one could help me and I
was like oh well there is no help there
what they're doing isn't working and
something like switched and I was like I
have to do this myself and then once I
decided there wasn't anyone I could go
to and I could do it my I had to do it
myself I didn't have an option that's
when I started getting better and I it's
because I started figuring things out
but something needed to switch in my
head for me to get to the point that I
could actually go out and search for
myself because for my entire life of
like well that's not really on me
and I wasn't brought up like that at all
right at all but um but still it was a
mind it was a definitely a switch in how
I was thinking
which I think can be helpful helpful for
people like you if there's a problem in
your life you have the ability to fix it
like and you have to go fix it or you're
stuck with this program problem for your
own your entire life right which is
terrible yeah that's right and also I
mean I in San Francisco I describe how
you know here out of the 60s we had this
really liberating philosophy of
of the human potential movement it sort
of gives rise to the self-help movement
you know I'm obsessed with Victor
Frankel his character in the book Man's
Search for meaning
this idea that that your mentality is
something that you can control that you
have some control over your mentality
and that if you can control your
mentality then you can control your life
it's the super deeply empowering
mentality and of course a long tradition
self-reliance and
the United States
well the left response to it I think
it's they kind of responded and they go
that's blaming the victim that's blaming
people
um if you are encouraging people to take
responsibility which is really
empowering you're actually
seeking to punish and blame them
and then that gave rise to all of it
victim ideology woke is um and so it's
there's a very I see the reaction to you
and your father has been very much from
people threatened that you that you guys
are basically in trying to empower other
people
they're you're under you're challenging
the control that that the radical left
that Progressive woke types exercise
over large parts of society in
convincing them that their victims
of forces beyond their control I mean
what could be more disempowering than
telling people that you are essentially
a victim by nature of your race or
experience or position in society and
there's nothing you can do about it
except support my political agenda
it's religiously disempowering and
oppressive and so when folks come along
like like you guys and say
oh my gosh no there's like there's all
there's you can you can take control of
your of your diet of your exercise of
your mentality of your energy levels you
can get control over your life that's
totally threatening to people that are
exercising inappropriate amounts of
control over other people
good
well that's thank you well Bravo to you
too that's why I wanted to have you on
my show like I said for a while
um I did it very much enjoy San
Francisco uh and your new book when is
it coming out you said 2024 yeah so I
have a book coming out next year called
the war on nuclear why it hurts us all
that's cool and that's that's kind of
like
um
you know like sometimes it's like the
outtakes to your last album so it's a
little bit like it's it's a little bit
like a side thing it's not the the it's
gonna be an important book but
um but for me there's also this Trilogy
of books which is apocalypse never San
Francisco and then Progressive nihilism
the working title of progressive
nihilism why civilized people undermine
civilization cool okay well we'll have
to have you back on
um when that comes out if anybody is
interested in following you where should
they go I mean Twitter is I love Twitter
right now so you can find me on Twitter
at shelumbergermd those are just my
initials I'm not a doctor schellenberger
MD or on Instagram I actually have just
my name which is great shelenberger
or my sub stack which has become the
really one of the only places I'm
writing for now just sub stack Michael
schollenberger.com cool okay I will link
all those below thank you very much for
coming on thanks for having me here a
little pleasure to meet you yeah nice
meeting you too
[Music]
thank you